like with my children personally right
if there's a situation I will explain to
my children like this is a situation
like dude between this person that
person depends on the situation of
course because they're still very young
but the children need to be aware
otherwise it's going to be like how it
was with her where no one told her
anything you just kept in a room
nothing I think you become westernizing
just become entitled to feel like you
that they deserve you deserve an
explanation because if a parent is
providing that is their core value like
I'm here to provide for you anything
else this is the reason why Zimbabwean
culture is I'm completely you have to be
able to speak to your child you can't
silence your children you guys do this
all the time oh Mom I'm going through
this
point you can't take boys
with a bunch of whiners where it's like
this problem that problem that they used
to live through plagues like they used
to live through real problem now we have
all this trauma this mental unstability
I'm not talking about you personally but
it's like it's like and you don't
deserve an explanation from your parents
forever
you don't deserve anything I do that the
world doesn't owe you [__] the world
urge me everything
yes he does yes like the world the world
owes you nothing if you don't explain to
your children certain situations and
they can't feel comfortable coming to Ox
you think a lot of times you're better
for not knowing certain situations I
don't want to know what my parents are
fighting about I don't want to know what
my parents mental health issues are like
a lot of times you're better for not
knowing things
to be honest right now I think you guys
are so privileged your parents did you a
favor by bringing into this country
right yeah my mom did thank you Mom yeah
but you think you're dead there's
nothing to play in that room well you
had to
he had to do it yeah you owed my mom
that at least that's the least he owed
my mind
I'm not gonna explain my dad's situation
because you guys are trying to make me
experience my father I'm not gonna do
that okay but he owed my mom that he
owned my mom he owed my mom you're
coming here and saying oh it's
Zimbabwean cultures yeah they are they
are my parents worked hard in a country
that right now
and bro no they don't really when you
had me I didn't choose for him to have
me know so he has a responsibility he's
obligated to look after me I'm a child
yeah he is going to look after you but
you don't have a responsibility to go
and ask for questions from I can ask my
father whatever I want and he should
answer me just like my sons can ask me
questions and I'll answer them no that's
a western mentality no it's not a
western mentality that's the reason why
that SIM card don't work you like oh
it's just I'll just say how does how
does Zim culture not work it doesn't
work like I'll say okay what outcome so
so I'm guessing Zim is more traditional
right very okay okay so so it's like the
woman submits to the her husband right
whether she's she's cheating on you or
not whether he's abusing or not you stay
women are happier in traditional
outcomes every stat will tell you this
women have more STDs they're more likely
to be depressed they're more likely to
be on antidepressants they're more
likely to have had an abortion in a more
50 50 modern society in traditional
countries operate in traditional
outcomes the women are happier they're
not happy they're miserable they pretend
no they're absolutely yeah faking it
yeah
presence
women are depressed more than ever in
human history but if it's traditional
right no matter whatever culture it is
you you can't get out even if you want
to get out you can't get out because
you're gonna think oh what about my
family what would the culture say yeah
and that's and that's better because
that was when mothers put their kids
before them it wasn't a me me culture
it's not about my happiness about your
kids your kids more likely to go to
prison they're more likely to be in a
mental institution they're more likely
to drop out of school you're putting
your kid at every statistical
disadvantage you can possibly put them
at by leaving
every statistical disadvantage sometimes
but modern women don't care because they
care about their feelings and not the
kids
but sometimes it's better to leave how
who is it better for you or the kids
so it might be better for you but if in
a toxic environment if you're in a
terrific relationship wrong if in a
toxic relationship it's better to leave
for body for your children and for
yourself but why are you arguing why is
the other person arguing with you women
it's it's your argument with us it's not
always us let's be realistic like you
don't have to argue back that's a choice
they need you have to sit there and take
it to find it nice Define abuse abuse
can be mentally physically I need you to
Define it because a lot of times women
we throw around these buzzwords that
don't mean anything anymore that guy is
physically assaulting you right it's
best to say in that marriage because
it's no no there's a physical assault is
a very minority of cases it's a minority
so that's the exception it's not the
rule
please give me another example outside
of assault
the so many okay
what is emotional abuse what is it
emotional abuses where they're
yeah like they're trying to control you
okay you can't do this you can't do that
you can't wear this you can't wait
that's that's my problem right there you
know when you come from Zim culture they
give you advice and you guys think
advice is control they give you guys
if you're gonna talk to my producer
You're Gonna Go you need to let him
spice I'm saying they come to give you
advice they've been through situations
right you have pretty much made into the
UK they they left a country where the
amount of people that are living the
country are like a small minority right
and it's a blessing to actually be able
to leave that country because of the
situation that's going on in that
country so they have all this life
advice these are people that used to
learn in difficult circumstances right
that some of them actually in zinc
culture went to war as well so they have
all their life experience they've heard
all these things like guidance pretty
much they want to give for you for your
life but you guys feel like it's control
because you want to be so liberal you
don't want to listen to your parents and
that's why I have a disagreement with
you guys because you want the Western
culture because it gives you that
liberalism that I can just do whatever I
want by doing whatever you want you have
no responsibility and you have no one to
account you
like right now you don't want to be
accountable to anybody so your parents
can tell you to do something you feel
like they're controlling you
but they can't we're grown
even when you were 17 when you left the
house you can advise me when I left when
I got for an hour you have to be clear
with that you have to be realistic with
that you can't just be like when you
left if I picked my I would have had all
my stuff if I wanted to leave yeah why
would I be going as well I was the one
sleep on the buses they were are you
challenged to Authority in the house
to me kicking me out and I said what I
said I said but I said after when he was
three I said oh I was already you had to
say something to be different what did I
say I got kicked off because I didn't
move at the house at a certain time
because of her and she's got an issue
with me hoovering at a certain time
because I got school anyway she
completely kicked it that whole
situation for no reason she got mad as
usual
I don't know what she said basically
because I didn't do it at the same time
she'll say okay in the mornings you have
to do the two around eight o'clock if
you're in someone's house you have to
listen to their rules but if the person
is changing the times just because they
want to get you in trouble you guys
would never understand there because
you're not in the situation anyway so I
don't I don't expect you to
my parents had divorced my mum and dad
are divorced my culture is Indian back
from India like my dad is from India my
mom was born here whatever right but
um
I was Minecraft story is crazy as well
like hey but that's due to my mom's
boyfriend
abusing me as well and that shows why
women shouldn't leave because it puts
their kid at risk
but you're proving my point
no she's not she's still not doing my
things
boyfriend are you guys both married well
not coming or not in a comments oh so
you guys are not married well maybe I
don't know I'm not married
it speaks to the facts
like step parents
that's the most likely person to abuse
your children is a guy that you bring
into the house that's the most likely
stat get like my mom's boyfriend when
she brought him into the house in the
beginning well what happened was
obviously my mom was doing my dad wrong
and I chose to go with my dad because my
dad and my mom both asked us like me and
my brother who we want to go with I
chose to go with my dad and then I'm the
one that took him to my Nan's house
because he had nowhere to go and I was
like let's just go to my Nan's house
because not sleeping on the road
so from there I was staying with my dad
and my dad started acting differently
towards me right and I was a kid myself
going through my parents being divorced
and he was all about my brother my
brother my brother and I'm here trying
to go to school and come back and make
sure my dad is okay right and then I
don't know what happened like why he
chose to abuse me well actually I do
know why is because I never asked my
mother a question that he wanted me to
ask because she kind of realized that my
dad was telling me what to say right so
then my dad assaulted me and I chose to
go back to my mother I went there
her boyfriend was when you say assaulted
he like what he hit you yeah and then
like multiple times yeah my grandparents
came to stop him when my Grandad wasn't
home but my nan and my uncles um had to
get him off me so after that I chose to
go back to my mom's right and I'm not
gonna lie like even though my mom did my
dad wrong I was missing my mother a
little bit I was like I'm gonna put my
hand up I was missing her so I chose to
go back to
um my mom and I also thought maybe my
dad will start caring more about me like
how he did with my brother right went
there her boyfriend's moved in he was
nice in the beginning and everything you
know how it bees because they want to
you know be like oh we care about you we
care about you then slowly slowly I
started to see his true colors
and it did not go well it did not go
well I got kicked out as well I got
kicked out at 16. I don't want to be
thrown out but I got kicked out because
of my mom's boyfriend because she chose
to listen to her man and
um an incident happened right I'm not
going to go too much into it but
there was a thing that he wanted to
happen through me right and my mother
was going along with it I found out and
I was in a relationship at the time with
my children's father was in a
relationship with him and then they
tried to split us up because obviously
her my mom's boyfriend wanted that thing
to happen and like a sexual thing
no it wasn't a sexual thing no no no no
no no it was not a sexual thing I can
clear that now it was not a sexual thing
at all it was it was regarding something
which I don't really want to say just in
case and um is it legal did you say it
was illegal yeah actually you can say it
was illegal because I was only 16 wasn't
I yeah so I was 16 so you can class it
as a legal but I'm not going to go too
much into what it was but um they tried
to split me and my children's father up
and because it did not work
so they tried to split you you guys you
they tried to have you guys break up
yeah because so his thing could be
successful in what he wanted
so so the the step dad could be
successful yeah he could be successful
so whatever he planned can happen but
um so he wanted to search you up with
someone else
a kind of like that button
not in this country if that makes sense
so like an arranged type marriage
I'm not gonna go into that I'm not yeah
I'm not gonna go into that at all but
basically what happens it's like the
theme Here is like you guys don't listen
to your parents no I used to listen I
actually used to um
well when my when I okay I'll start from
the beginning when I was growing up my
brother was always the favorite right
and because he's a boy who cares he was
a boy so he was always the favorite I
always felt left out so I was always
going to my grandparents house yeah they
always like the boys exactly who cares
like my dad liked my brother like who
cares yeah so I went to this victim like
boohoo it's like I was like whatever
anyways yeah yeah it didn't bother me
because I was my grandpa's favorite so I
was like how shame but yeah you got it
you gotta go take it where you can get
it yeah yeah all right I'm getting stuff
from them you can carry on you know
whatever it is father's always love
their sons more like come on my mom is
wrong my mom loves to my brother more as
well but um she's like a great guy no
maybe he's just a really cool
maybe he's just a cool guy if he was
my brothers my my parents favorite and I
get it I'm like it's a cool dude right
yeah there's a thing but like if your
sibling is your parents favorite that's
fine I don't have a problem with that
but
my brother's not a cool guy I'll put my
hand up to that he's not a cool guy no
he's not if he was I would say yeah my
brother is you know we've got a tight
relationship I love my brother he's
amazing with my children I would say
that okay it's not but he's not a cool
guy so he didn't deserve favoritism
it just seems like there's a lot of
problems here that would go better like
if we just listen to our parents so I
hope I listen to my parents
I used to listen to my parents and my
mom allowed her boyfriend
seems it also seems like it also seems
like life would be easier if families
stayed together because your mom's
boyfriend wouldn't be in that position
and maybe I'm not really talking about
you personally like I'm just talking
about in general I just think it's
better if families stay together yeah if
it does yeah it'll be better